[Music]
in celebrity drama news huh submitted by
lost camarones there's not a boxing
match
Mobe is canceling his book tour
following a controversy with Natalie
Portman not moby moby he's so proud of
it the [ __ ] is Moby
he's the bald guy with glasses that
talks really thank you like 2001
techno music there you go good Moby
better now I have no idea who that guy
is
you know the slim shady side which one
Moby you could get stomped by Obi you 36
year old bald-headed slow mean he was
roasting him but no one already
no one already knew who he was but now
and I'm like 10 years older than that so
he's uh yep he's like known for being
vegan now too and like being an animal
activist person he was always annoying
as the thing maybe he's big with the
older crowd like people that was like
five ten years older than us
no it was our age really yeah he used to
techno techno that wasn't even hype it
was kind of hype - no York is is weird
I love Bjork but not even heard of her
though I'm like I [ __ ] love was it
Bjork song you won't even know there's
no good it really isn't anything popular
that song called squiddy calamari it's
not like she's not like poppy like that
I have York record right behind you a CD
record [ __ ] CD [ __ ]
yeah she's really artsy is she the [ __ ]
that worth I mean is she the porcupine
the [ __ ] this one yes yeah she was
making fun of her yeah I like that one
alright that's the one
what no no miss Swann from MADtv she she
made fun of Bjork by where his furry
suit oh I see that's what I was thinking
of the porcupine yeah she was making fun
anyway so movi cancelled his UK and
Ireland dates of his book tour promoting
his new memoir called
then it fell apart Oh terrible I'm
already teen Natalie Portman I love her
yeah so this whole thing is because he
mentioned Natalie Portman in his book
and he describes dating her you go to
date Natalie Portman that free oh let me
claim and so she so he claimed that
Natalie Portman invited him to meet up
after a concert in 1999 when he was 33
and she was 20 this is what it says in
the book but in reality she was actually
18 years old I was gonna say that was a
Star Wars day is like she was young as
[ __ ] back then 18 20 same thing though
so then he says I was a bald binge
drinker and Natalie Portman was a
beautiful movie star but there she was
in my dressing room
flirting with sucking my dick oh this is
what he wanted down Natalie Portman
Injection had an interview with Harper's
Bazaar and she said quote I was
surprised to hear that he characterized
the very short time that I knew him as
dating because my recollection is a much
older man being creepy with me when I
had when I just had graduated high
school he said I was twenty I definitely
wasn't I was a teenager I had just
turned 18 see so then she added that
when they met after the show he said
let's be friends and he was on tour and
she was working shooting on a movie on a
film stars they only hung out a handful
of times before she realized that this
is an older man who was interested in
her in a way that felt inappropriate
that's what that interview said so then
in response movi posted photos of him
with Natalie Portman it doesn't mean
anything you mean you weren't creepy
yeah so he posted like this
she looks creeped out yeah that looks
like a fret year but the creepiest one
was this photo where he's shirtless and
then he writes he's a creep he writes I
recently read a gossip piece where
Natalie Portman said that we'd never
dated this confused me as we did in fact
date and after briefly dating in 1999 we
remained friends for years
I like Natalie and I respect her
intelligence and activism but to be
honest I can't figure out why she would
actively misrepresent the truth about
our lv8 brief involvement the story has
laid out in my book then it fell apart
is accurate with lots of corroborating
photo evidence exact etc thanks Moby and
then he says PS I completely respect
Natalie as possible regret and dating me
parentheses to be fair I would probably
regret dating me too but it doesn't
alter the actual facts you know what it
sounds like it sounds like um like
Natalie was trying to be classy and
saying like he was a [ __ ] creep and
probably threw himself on her and she
was just protecting like yeah like it
was just I felt it was weird so I just
kind of removed myself from that and he
probably tried kissing her and they
probably did kiss her she's he probably
kissed her when they were drunk and
thought like they were dating yeah he
sounds like that friendzone guy that
thinks and tells everyone yeah we used
to date but it was just him coming on to
her she is so [ __ ] pretty I know
she's really pretty because in those
pictures she doesn't look she looks like
they're homies
yeah body language I forget how pretty
Natalie Portman is how could you forget
bald Natalie Portman so finally what she
bought you for Vendetta she's [ __ ]
pretty as hell she's up there now she's
like plenty
yeah she's classic beautiful yeah so
then he posted all these other different
pose all stop dude you're making
yourself look really bad yeah conspiracy
time what if they really did but then
she can leak out the truth because she
said I'm during that time there was
other things going on with another
person or maybe huge is creepy yeah I
know but we already went through that
that's really fun that's not fun we got
to add some other [ __ ] cuz maybe it's
because like you know makes her look bad
yeah like she's dating
you know like oh yeah so tarnishes are
trying to see if I could borrow you
because Billy Bob is dope yeah he's an
old dope guy
Moby's like oh whoa be but looking at
the body language though from those
photos that's not romantic involvement
if they have one photo of her like
kissing his cheek or even like this type
of hug like she's literally like this he
were friends what if like her hand was
like in his pants and then coming out of
the zipper like look at this one look at
her hips are like definitely making sure
to stay away from him
my vote goes to every convention I know
you tube ski convention Comic Con
[ __ ] convention she looks like she
came to visit him from a make-a-wish
Foundation that's like that's just a
creepy pity that doesn't look like their
room it looks like he's been going over
yeah [ __ ] pretty dude look at that
face hand is all over her like this was
very weird grip too because there's no
palm attachment it's just like this
[ __ ] rock climbing grip yeah she has
a really tiny frame maybe yes
Mobe like I said she posted a lot of
other things but the last one he posted
says this last post they're really far
apart in that one and the caption says
I'm going to go away for a while [ __ ]
embarrassing so he says but before I do
I want to apologize again and to say
clearly that all of this has been my own
fault I am the one who released the book
without showing it to the people I wrote
about and the one who posted defensive
and arrogantly I'm the one who behaved
inconsiderately and disrespectful leave
both in 2019 and in 1999 there is
obviously no one else to blame but me
thank you and I'm sorry
oh dude Maz dude what's happening oh
what a mature person what's his name
really it was a minute fell apart still
falling
yeah that's the second book it's still
falling apart this guy like come up with
music a little bit and then started to
fall apart it from 1999 and he's in the
limelight
just following apart the whole way
through poor dude man cuz I hear about
him once in a while but I'm like but
it's always like it used to be that guy
from that night for the nineties
you got the bald guy with the glasses
yeah I don't remember any song by
Lumberton late 90s early 2000s super
relevant I don't know why he had a song
that kept playing on the radio yeah but
it was just like a it was like a techno
song that was okay for a mainstream like
it was like a but he existed for a while
that name like lasted for yes you know I
don't even care if I'm washed up as long
as I got something like that
yeah it's like you're washed up that
doesn't matter people know who I am
[ __ ] he's washed up and it's still
above the success of every I know
exactly that's what happens Eminem
destroys careers they still that's the
weird thing the one when people they
look at a celebrity they go
we caught washed-up you are he goes they
still have millions of dollars so if
that's washed and he still okay
and he still had you got the chance to
talk to man he'd watch Natalie Portman
with his fingers and she's my favorite
actress your favorite of all time
really for what reason well garden
state's my favorite movie I love that
movie me too and self she's what does
garden state's a movie what was it about
it's like an Indian type film it's like
Zach Braff oh I dunno Garden State the
dope is [ __ ] soundtrack yeah it's a
good soundtrack cuz him and Zach Braff
and the shins are friends so I was like
promoting them in there and that's when
everyone kind of found out about the
shins
yeah and it just could be like really
good acting it's like a I remember
Garden State I was watching it on the
plane
as one of those old classic movies I
fell asleep it's a lot about mental hell
yeah yeah she killed it in that and then
I just followed her career since see her
when she was a kid god yeah it was a
professional yes yeah it did see that
one yeah how'd they get the assassin I
pretty much seen every Natalie Portman
fill yes she's one of the very few kid
actors that hasn't had a crazy you know
that movie was about my less spacious
doctor star wars she took a break I went
to college graduated from
Harvard or something like one of those
big top yeah yeah and then she came back
to acting later so she had a normal life
for a little bit so that's why she's so
well-adjusted
does she make up make out what that guy
at the end and then she went down the
the the laundry chute they didn't make
out the professional maybe that's
another movie I think you're mixing your
porn with girl movies no it's another
movie well it's another guy protecting a
little girl but she's like eight I know
and at the end they they [ __ ] make
out and then she goes down the laundry
chute and I'm like maybe like a kiss if
it was that better remember that either
who was the one that was a crazy
babysitter that wanted to [ __ ] the guy
the dad American Beauty Alicia
Silverstone that one that was creepy
Alicia Silverstone what movie she was
like a babysitter or something and then
she was like super creepy I remember
that movie you know she was hot she
scared me it was Alicia Silverstone yeah
she was in a lot of [ __ ] back then I
remember blonde haired nice lips
American Beauty no American beauties a
great movie to watch yet little sister
vibes oh really
yeah I never liked her American Beauty
was a great movie Brooke Shields my top
favorite oh [ __ ] yeah what's that island
movie when she was really young Brooke
Shields is probably one of the most
beautiful people that has ever existed
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]